es gibt neues kurioses zum thema
vielfalt wer buntes in deutschland was
es dann los ja das mag ich aber jetzt
mal mit deutschlands schnellster meinung
wer will ich hier nicht hin und logo
heute morgen halte die will ja keiner
hören und zwei das ist der wahnsinn auf
dem parkplatz man sieht es schon hier
auf dem bild dessen vielfalt parkplatz
also da ist ein platz reserviert für die
lgbt community das ist bestimmt ganz gut
gemeint und das hat auch jemand sich da
von goisern noch von der organisation
ist also die jetzt gemacht und gesagt
hanau ist das übrigens und hat gesagt ja
wir wollten damit aufmerksam machen mit
der regenbogenfahne also es ist ganz gut
gemeint aber das ist natürlich überhaupt
nicht umsetzbar also sollen soll es
jetzt einen
stein aus welt geben wo irgendwie die
sexuelle orientierung drauf steht also
es ist halt wieder ein absoluter
wahnsinn wo man sich denkt toll dass
sich so viele menschen in deutschland
gedanken machen das ja alle miteinander
sind aber ehrlich gesagt ist es doch
völlig egal welche sexuelle orientierung
man hat fünf parkplatz her das hängt ja
schon an frauenparkplätzen mutter kind
parkplätzen also den einzigen parkplatz
sind ja wirklich ausweisen kann ist ein
behindertenparkplatz wenn du ein
behindertenausweis hast aber es ist halt
immer schwierig mutter kind parkplatz
macht ja noch sinn da geht es ja auch um
die sicherheit
die frage ist natürlich geht er jetzt
auch für mich wenn ich hier mein kind
vielleicht jetzt gerade nicht dabei
haben den kindersitz habe ich ja drin
und so wer will das überhaupt
kontrollieren das ist halt immer die
frage unter stimmt was damals gesagt mit
den frauen parkplätzen ist ja immer nah
am ausgang dagegen trauen nicht durch
dunkle parkhaus da sehe ich irgendwie
ich hatte noch nie angst aber da sehe
ich so ein bisschen den sinn aber das
ist hier halt wieder da hätten sie
vielleicht einfach nur die
regenbogenfahne machen sollen ohne die
parkplätze auszuweisen wenn sie nur
darauf aufmerksam machen wollten für
mich der wahnsinn des tages aber es ist
ja immer netter gedanke dahinter ich
will jetzt die stadt diesen diesen
tiefgaragen parkplatzbesitzer in hanau
jetzt auch nicht federn und thelen ich
glaube der hat sich ja was bei gedacht
schlecht umgesetzt
[Musik]